It's great to welcome back to the program
today.
Congressman Roe Karna representing California's
17th District, located in the heart of Silicon
Valley.
Where to start?
Right.
I mean, I think maybe the first place would
be second stimulus, given what's going on
with coronavirus discussions of a payroll
tax, discussions of an extension or expansion.
And to what degree of this enhanced unemployment?
What are your priorities?
What do you think needs to happen and when?
Well, first, we have to be clear eyed about
what the problem is.
The problem is that there are not enough jobs.
I mean, people don't have enough money to
pay basic rent to get groceries.
So when people say, oh, these unemployment
checks are some disincentive to work, they're
five times the job seekers as there are jobs.
And the irony is that by not giving this money,
it's not just that we're doing enormous damage
to middle class and working class families.
I mean, some are having foreclosures.
Some aren't being able to get enough nutritious
food for their kids.
It's also that we're damaging the economy
because the economy is stalling.
If people don't have money to spend.
So the priority has to be to stick to the
six hundred dollars to get that extended through
the end of the year to get funding for states
and localities.
Of course, as you know, David, I've been pushing
for two thousand dollars a month for for people
that wasn't in the House bill.
So I don't want to mislead people and it's
unrealistic that's going to be in the cards
for this.
But but we have to stick to the six hundred
dollars, the stimulus and the funny money
for state and local governments.
I was initially at least sort of loosely open
to the idea of the payroll tax cut that has
been floated by Donald Trump.
I then changed my mind because I realize that
it seems like a way to weaken Social Security
and Medicare and then maybe use that deliberate
weakening as a reason to justify further weakening
or defunding.
So I ended up deciding I didn't like it.
And in particular because the way I read it,
it's only a holiday.
It is not actually a cut.
In other words, you would then on your taxes
when you file, potentially owe it back.
And so I ended up saying, I don't like it.
Where are you on it?
Yeah, I don't think it makes sense, particularly
because we have the challenge now of businesses
not opening.
I mean, if you if you work for a restaurant
or indoor dining, it doesn't matter if you
have a payroll tax cut.
That's not going to get you back to work until
the virus is under control.
And I don't see it getting under control until
next year, until we have a vaccine and better
therapeutics.
So you could argue in a traditional recession,
a payroll tax cut may provide some added incentive
to the hiring.
It favors businesses over workers.
But you may say, OK, we need it as one tool.
But in a pandemic where the ability to create
new jobs is restricted by public health, I
don't think it makes sense.
So I'm curious whether you have any other
as a member of the House, insight into what
we might call the real case numbers.
And what I mean by that is a couple of examples
are we saw this leveling off after July 16th,
which was exactly when data started going
to HHS instead of the CDC.
It's a question mark, although I'm not alleging
deliberate foul play yet.
But then on top of that, Florida's numbers
have gone down.
But they stopped testing on Thursday because
of the hurricane and only restarted yesterday.
So that would be a very clear reason why we
don't have a complete picture there.
The California covered 19 dashboard yesterday
put up a message saying that for several days,
cases had been underreported, although the
reason why is not yet clear to me.
Are you working with the same data the public
is working with?
You have any other insights into into more
accurate data?
We're working with the same data.
We don't get any briefing of better data.
And I say whether it's deliberate, I don't
know.
But it's certainly not transparent.
I mean, there's been a lot of obfuscation.
There isn't a clear way of collecting this
data.
And the reality is it's the hospitalizations
and the deaths that continue to be outrageous.
I mean, especially when you look at other
countries, the cases, of course, matter.
But the No.
One is can dispute the data that we still
don't have this under control, given the amount
of deaths that we're unfortunately facing
and given the amount of hospitalization we're
facing.
The topic of cases, cases versus tests, if
you don't test, you don't find cases, case
fatality rate versus deaths per capita.
This all kind of exploded on Monday night
in this interview that the president gave
to Axios.
Jonathan Swann, I'm guessing you saw the interview.
I did.
I mean, and, you know, it's very hard.
The president has one skill.
He's he's very good at marketing and branding.
But you can't spin death.
You can't market when people are in hospitals
or film.
And so he was trying to say when the relevant
statistic is the percentage of people with
cases who are dying.
And it is true that that percentage has gone
down as treatments have improved.
But that is not the relevant statistic.
A relevant statistic is not what percentage
of people are getting covered or dying.
The relevant statistic is why are so many
Americans getting covered compared to other
countries?
And I think the president was unable to spin
his way out of that.
He obviously had.
Stands the distinction, he's just hoping that
he can fool people.
But you can't fool people when it's their
own public health.
That's interesting.
So you think he does understand these these
issues in more detail than maybe he lets on
and he's spinning because I actually question
whether he understands some of this stuff.
Your sense is that it's deliberate and that
it's optics.
I think in that case, it's I mean, I don't
think he's deeply reflective, but I think
he looks for the numbers that make the most
sense and he tries that to put them out.
If if the death rates were lower, he would
have put that number out.
So I. I think his modus operandi his whole
life has been take any news, exaggerated a
bit, make it sound good.
Great.
And to your advantage.
And in many cases that has work with him,
with people who are busy in their lives and
don't have the time to look through long articles.
The challenge here is suddenly people are
taking the time to pay attention because it's
their own house.
It's their parents' house.
It's their neighbor's house.
And so they have far more details.
And when you have a situation of an engaged
citizenry on an issue, Trump strategy really
falls flat.
And that's why I think you've seen him struggling.
What do you think?
I guess let me rephrase it in a different
way.
I imagine that if you were scheduled to do
an interview that your staff felt very strongly
would potentially be a disaster, that you
logic would reach you and you might listen
to advice that says this maybe isn't a good
interview to do.
The context is, how do you think these insane
interviews are even happening with the president?
Is it that he doesn't listen to his staff
and that he believes he'll always come out
on top?
I mean, I'm trying to understand how these
things are happening so frequently.
Yeah.
I think from his perspective, he's succeeded.
Quote unquote, succeeded in a material sense
that a lot of things he's done in life, he's
managed to talk himself out of bankruptcy
as he came out of nowhere and became president
of the United States.
And I think he has a lot of self-confidence
and hubris that his view is the more exposure,
the better, and that he can talk his way out
of anything.
And this is a common problem when people become
president.
Obviously, it's massively exaggerated in Trump's
case, where he does not have the humility
to see his own weaknesses.
And I think that's creating a large amount
of the problems for him.
So what what does that get you thinking about
in terms of potential Biden vs. Trump debates?
I've said from a practical standpoint, I can't
think of an election I voted in where I care
less about seeing debates.
I mean, it's just I just think I have more
than enough information, uniquely so in this
case, to make a decision.
And that's that's to vote for Joe Biden.
There's speculation about Joe Biden.
The debates are better for Biden or the debates
are better for Trump.
And a lot of that depends on, you know, what
your belief is about the cognitive state of
either or both of them.
What's your sense about the debates?
Not generally, but in this particular case?
Well, I think that Biden will debate and should
debate because I think the story of him not
debating would be a much bigger deal and lead
to speculation that is unfair and wrong.
And I think people underestimate Biden.
I mean, if you look at you know, I co-chair
of the Bernie Sanders campaign, we were very
excited when we had a one on one opportunity
with Biden.
And I think everyone will tell you that Biden
held his own.
I mean, it was not a knockout punch for Bernie
Sanders of anything.
I think it was probably a draw.
So my sense is Biden's debate skills improved
a lot through the course of the primary.
And I think one of the mistakes Donald Trump
is making is by so putting all his chips in
these debates and setting the bar so low,
if Biden has a satisfactory performance, is
going to really, I think, get the upper hand.
And I think Biden's tape perfectly capable
of having a solid performance.
That's super interesting, because I remember
that in the sort of Twitter Bernie space before
the one on one debates, there were very high
hopes that Joe Biden was going to implode.
And this was God.
That was going to be the moment at which Bernie
took over.
And as you mention, it really was a draw in
a sense.
I do think that the heavy focus on Corona
virus probably helped Joe Biden to some degree.
And there was less focus in that debate on
on other issues.
But so even within the Bernie camp, there
were high hopes about that one on one debate.
Yeah, no, I mean, that was sort of our final
hope to try to shake up the race.
Obviously, we were doing very well headed
into Super Tuesday.
We had a different disappointing Super Tuesday.
It was a not anticipated that everyone was
withdrawn and endorsed by the.
It's a free country.
People can do that.
But really, no one thought the establishment
would coalesce around by them that quickly.
And so we needed a game changer and we thought
this debate was a place we could have won.
I mean, Bernie.
Actively, I think, and done much better in
a lot of the debates leading up to that debate
than Biden had.
Biden is exceeded expectations in that debate.
And so he's certainly capable of doing that.
And so I think Trump is making a mistake if
he's putting all his eggs in in that basket.
So let's talk a little bit about the last
three months here to the election where every
member of the House is up for reelection,
33 plus two Senate seats are available.
And, of course, it's the presidential election.
There are some in my audience that are feeling
very confident about the presidential piece,
seeing polls that have Joe Biden doing very
well today.
I went through and pointed out, for example,
in a recent poll where Joe Biden is winning
by nine.
When you look at the margin of error, that
could be actually only a two point four percent
lead for Joe Biden.
And Hillary won by two point two in 2016 at
the popular vote level, but lost the Electoral
College.
When I look at state by state polling, which
looks quite good for Joe Biden, the state
polling was not great in 2016.
National was good.
In other words, Hillary was up three and one
by two point two.
That's that's great.
Wisconsin said Hillary was going to win and
she lost.
So I am very cautious about any complacency
at all going into this election.
While some are extraordinarily confident.
What do you think is the right perspective
on the data?
I think caution is better.
I would say if the election were tomorrow,
Biden would win because I think the the polling
is so overwhelming in one direction.
But the election is not tomorrow and there's
a lot that can happen in the next 90 days.
The debates being one of them.
That doesn't mean don't debate because that
would be an issue in and of itself.
But the point is that the conventions haven't
happened.
The debates haven't happened.
We don't know what the economy is going to
look like.
Come end of September and October.
We don't know whether coronaviruses is going
to be on the retreat.
In some sense and getting slightly better
or whether it's getting worse.
We don't know the impact of who he picks of
the vice president.
So this is not a situation of George W. Bush
in 2008 where George W. Bush collapsed into
the 30s and really the American people had
totally written him off.
And I don't think it's even at the level of
Jimmy Carter Rubin been I really admired Jimmy
Carter.
I think he was an exceptional person.
But Trump has been stubbornly at 40, 41, 42.
That means if he gets a five point swing and
gets his approval up to forty five, this is
a very competitive race.
And then he put it, if you put on top of that
this fact that the voter suppression.
The difficulty of mail in ballots, the energetic
nature of his base.
And I think we have to assume that this is
going to be a drag out fight.
When it comes to the Senate, it looks to me
as though if Democrats keep the House, which
you are projected to, if Joe Biden were to
win, that a lot of what gets done in the next
two years depends on whether Democrats can
take control of the Senate.
And I've looked at the races up and down,
and certainly there's a path now that is a
clearer path than than it was six and 12 and
18 months ago.
What races are you looking at in the Senate?
And what's your sense of where that might
go?
I think Arizona, we've got a great job with
Mark Kelly.
I think in North Carolina with Cunningham,
we have a very, very strong shot.
I think Susan Collins is in deep trouble.
I think Steve Bullock in Montana has made
that race much more competitive.
Our candidates are doing very well.
But I think it largely depends on on Biden.
I mean, if if Biden has a kind of win that
he is polling currently shows, I think we
have a very good chance of carrying the Senate.
If this race tightens, as I fear it may, then,
you know, our chances of getting a sweep we
need in Senate seats becomes harder and it
became harder where some of the candidates
won the right candidates from the Republican
side in the Kansas primary.
And, you know, they have and they've been
fortunate not to elect some of the most crazy
people where we could have had a pickup opportunity.
Last thing I want to touch on, there's been
this idea now of could an election be delayed?
What would it look like?
What would be the reasons?
Are there ways for the president to stay in
the Oval Office?
And I've tried not to give this more attention
than it deserves, because when when it comes
right down to it, we've not had a federal
election delay in the history of this country.
On January 20th.
Trump stops being president if he's not reelected.
And then, you know, a series of other things
happen.
Is this at all being taken seriously among
you and your colleagues?
Is there is there discussion of this or is
it basically just not not being paid attention
to?
My concern is not that he's going to delay
the election.
My concern is that there is a early reporting
of Election Day results where which tend to
favor Republicans traditionally.
And he may be have an early lead and well
in one of these battleground states.
And then there's delay and not proper counting
of absentee ballots.
And if you have a few percent election in
a place like Florida in a place like Wisconsin,
that there's tremendous pressure put on the
state legislatures to certify those states
in favor of Trump.
So I don't see a situation where the state
certified Joe Biden in the House and Senate
certified Joe Biden and Donald Trump stays
in the White House.
I think a far more risky situation is like
1876, where you actually have state legislatures
working, conspiring with the White House to
give the result to Trump on on a on a close
call.
And that that to me is the the disenfranchisement.
And states calling it for Trump are what what
I think are the deep concerns.
Yeah, I'm not conspiratorial by nature, but
after months of railing against vote by mail,
when Donald Trump tweeted two days ago or
three days ago, everybody in Florida should
vote by mail.
My mind immediately goes to what does he know
about Ron DeSantis, his plans that now all
of a sudden make him very into the idea of
Florida voting by mail.
And I think it goes along the lines you're
talking about, which is the role that the
state and secretaries of states may have.
Yeah.
I mean, Luckies doesn't even try to get principle
a any any do.
I mean, he's basically saying, OK, in the
states that I need absentee voting, please
vote absentee in the states where absentee
voting may hurt me.
Don't do it.
It's just raw power.
But this is they understand that if it were
an election where which was clean, where everyone
who should be wanting to should be voting
and wanting to vote votes, Trump can't overcome
those numbers.
So the disenfranchisement, the tried trying
to create confusion.
And then the biggest risk, I think, is this
idea that Donald Trump imagine up on election
days, up by a couple of points in Wisconsin
or Florida, even if a week later we know he's
going to lose by four or five points.
You could see him declaring victory.
And it becomes much harder then for the states
where those state legislators are in Trump
heavy districts to do the right thing.
And so that that, I think, is the bigger,
bigger fear of how they would cheat or take
but take the election.
I completely agree.
And it's exactly the point that I've been
making.
Congressman Roe Kanha, representing California's
17th District.
Always a pleasure and I really appreciate
your time.
Appreciate it.
Appreciate all of your time.
And look forward to being back on